this is a production of Cornell
University
so I'm going to be presenting today
trying to understand the co inheritance
of two traits that are very important
for a building program we're using a
method called regional corporate ability
mapping now I'll go into that so I have
a picture about what conventional
cassava looks like smelly white to cream
and then this is what we call the yellow
cassava which is an effort by harvest
plus two for bio fortified cassava with
protocol in a and so harvest clause it's
a program with the CG systems and and
with cassava the main target is
programming a and in fact beta-carotene
is the programming a that is targeted
but total carotenoids which shows itself
a silly look coloration of the flesh
it's a good proxy for measuring
beta-carotene because the process of
measuring data correction is HPLC M is
kind of tedious so we have a prevalent
problem right now with the yellow
cassava the yellow cassava has
drastically low dramatic content and
this is a problem because in fact the
value of cassava is to drive matter
content and the yield that it that it
gets we get per hectare so there has
been reports mainly most African
building programs of a negative
correlation between this dry matter and
this yellow coloration of tubers and the
Hardin County reports in South America I
can see at Columbia they don't see this
negative correlation so we think is
majorly in the African
I'm plasm so the motivation is to
understand the genetic business of this
negative correlation and to do this we
employ a method we turn the regional
co-head ability mapping and now walk
through the procedure so the procedure
starts by fitting a bivariate G block
model and the traits our diameter and D
be a value from a kilometer I think it's
what is called and it just measures the
color so we take the be the dry matter
trade we fitted by very G blob using
this model and in fact the way the model
is fitted is that we have a stack of the
two traits and we see the X matrix is
the in our model he's just for the
location effects because the data was
collected from multiple locations and
then we show the genomic effect in U and
here we show that these effects have has
covariance from two covariances one from
DK which is a decomposition of the
genomic leadership matrix that comes
from markers and VG which is the trait
bitrate covariance matrix that we are
estimating the same goes for arrow and
for Harrow is simplified because we have
an identity matrix showing no
correlation between data points and we
fit this model and then the next thing
back solve to best knit effects from
from from these values from the genomic
values and Smith effects are estimated
by multiplying the transpose of the maca
matriz this maka matrix is centered
multiplied by the inverse of the genomic
relationship matrix and the estimated
genomic effect from
each trade so after you back souls we
try to standardize again using just like
we make how we make a G matrix using the
denominator from Bernadin at all 2008
and then the next thing is that we being
sneaky FEX within chromosomes into
segments and this segment are unique
3,000 snips and they are actually unique
there is no overlap so we divide the
chromosome into different segments we
tend this genomic segments and when we
have been them of course there are a
detail end of the chromosome some of
them are less than 3000 so after being
them we solve for clonal genomics
segment values and which commit for this
by multiplying the maca matrix again we
do Smitty FET that was calculated prior
and and then we correlate this clonal
genomic segment values with cloner for
dry matter and cloner genomic segment
values for the bit rate and this is how
we get the correlation for each segment
so these were modeled using block
personality programs and other matrix
computations were done in our so the
data for the analysis was majorly
genetic gain population the entik gain
is a breeding population from the ITA
and then we had been merged since the
70s so we use only data collected in two
years
so we use the dry matter and the D trait
as I said previously but we have a
second trait we call a sorry third trait
we call pop color and this is a binary
trait that actually measures
the color of the the root which is one
for white and then two for did cream to
yellow we use about this number of GBS
nips 451 clones for white 262 clones for
yellow that I was from three locations
and we we do this analysis in the older
populations white yellow and white plus
yellow scuse me so this is the result
from white plus yellow so each bar is
3,000 snip segment each color so as you
go from black to red to black to red so
each color difference is a new
chromosome and what we see from this
analysis is if you look at the skills
this here in Y the estimated genetic
correlation and in X of course the
chromosomes
you see we see an overwhelmingly
negative correlation at chromosome 1 and
then it seems that other chromosomes are
a bit slight or neutral this is for both
white and yellow populations and we'll
move to the white we see a different
result if you look at the scales of the
genetic correlation and white we observe
like a strong strong correlation here
not strong in terms of the value but
this segment shows very strong
correlation and then we also see
something here that most of the of the
segments in white are positive for the
TV but we have observed positive
correlations so to move to yellow we see
something that we sorry we see something
we saw in the previous one with white
and yellow but different in our cause is
that
we see that almost if at all apart from
the neutral ones overwhelmingly
negatively correlated for the yellow so
what does this show before we we go to
discussion I want to show this genetic
correlation from the bivariate model
itself not not the mapping and in white
we have we observe a positive
correlation and yellow observe a strong
negative correlation and when you have
both we have a weak negative correlation
so the correlation stems to they tend to
be consistent between these and the maps
and we observe is very strong negative
correlation for the yellow so what does
this mean for the program it means that
this several development of high dry
matter white varieties and in fact this
product is already in high demand in
Africa but for the food and stretch
industries and we will recommend a
separate beta program for this and then
if you move to yellow we observe
overwhelming that it does sever yellow
variety development and this is indeed
discouraging because of the high hopes
we have for habits plus but there has
been a lot of effort already towards
this and in fact a lot of clones are
brought in from CH and used in the
brilliant program for this and it's
ongoing now we see the result and it's
also a good target for Chris wife if if
we find what is going on completely and
in fact there is also chance that there
can be a recombinant who knows when this
happens and in conclusion want to
highlight what is going on in chromosome
one chromosome one is one that we know
already that there is an integration
that happened in the thirties or after
that as well in most cultivated cassava
in Africa and chromosome one seems to be
the culprit in this case but chromosome
one is also good for dry matter so it's
a very difficult case and we actually
showing the methodology because it shows
very good way to see what is going on
between these two traits and in the end
we think that they'll give some progress
from the results thank you very much
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu